welcome to las vegas now on this monday
june
7. you might know a.j mclean as the bad
boy from the backstreet boys but there's
more to him than meets the eye
our producer natalia sat with him to
talk about his
life now his music and of course las
vegas
aj was in town over the weekend for a
special performance part of the music
for life event for the victoria's voice
foundation
an organization with the purpose to
reduce drug abuse and overdose deaths
something that the singer is familiar
with
drugs and alcohol doesn't matter how old
you are
it it it doesn't pick and choose that um
you know and it is an absolute shame
that
this family lost a child
because of drugs and alcohol so coming
together raising money raising awareness
and hopefully spreading knowledge and
if anything that i leave here after this
is to tell anybody out there that you're
not alone
as a way to help and connect with others
with sober living mental health and life
aj along with dancing with the star's
partner cheryl burke and long time
friend elizondo
created their podcast called pretty
messed up where they have conversations
that might not necessarily be always
easy but are important to have them
paths crossed all three of us are sober
so it became like oh well this just
makes sense there was just an instant
chemistry
and we do have a lot in common we've all
crashed and burned
we've all been able to regain our lives
back
that's been another upside to this
pandemic for me the silver lining is
being home
being off the road being out of harm's
way
and being able to really focus on my
sobriety
and be able to focus on myself
and that's exactly what aj mclean has
done he has focused on himself
and through that we have new music
including a new song that is not only a
bop
but also shares an uplifting feeling and
an even better message of acceptance
[Music]
and to spread love and acceptance
self-love
self-care and to just be
kind of hopefully spearheading a new a
new movement of just
happiness i love it you can
find the love song love as well as his
podcast pretty messed up
on all music streaming platforms and we
have more of our interview with aj
mclean from the backstreet boys
in tomorrow show he'll be sharing a very
unforgettable vegas memory
and so much more las vegas now we'll be
right back